uh Mark Harper they says he wants you to
get off the picket line around the table
well that's fine it's
fine I hope I'd go and meet him now if
he wants or he can come here and meet me
and we can Hammer some things out what
we keep hearing is the same stuff from
the government uh across the sectors
that they want to facilitate
an agreement but they don't actually do
anything I met the rail Minister on the
15th along with the companies
we've heard nothing tangible since then
you hear a few warm words and Mark
Harper makes you know he conducts
himself in in a pleasant way in a good
way and that's fine so what we need to
hear now from the government is is
exactly what it is they're going to
propose to us at the moment
they they got themselves into a position
before Christmas where we were making
progress with the trade operating
companies and on one Sunday afternoon
before a set of strike action they
decided to torpedo those talks by
putting in conditions on in the
documentation that they know that we and
the other unions can never accept so
that was a deliberate strategy which
frustrated the train operating company
Executives the most senior people in the
industry are as frustrated as we are
that the government will not facilitate
a settlement and indeed is taking the
opposite tank of undermining efforts to
get a settlement they know that we can't
accept the current proposal so we need
to get a fresh
set of elements in the equation so that
we can work up some solutions rather
than just put in some warm words so as
soon as Mark Harper and his team want to
meet us will be available okay well he
said he wants to meet you this week but
you're on the picket line so he said
he's going to meet you next week but on
that specific point about torpedo
um
I don't understand the question to you
first Mr Lynch hold on so one sec on
that particular point about the
government torpedoing the negotiations I
put that to him just now he said that
that's just not true they haven't done
that
well he's not telling you the truth
because we had a document with the train
operating companies that did not include
driver only operation it was taken away
for approval in Whitehall at the DFT and
they inserted about eight or nine bullet
points that completely undermined the
negotiations that was a direct
intervention of government ministers we
know that to be true and if he's saying
that didn't happen he's simply not
telling you the whole truth well he and
let me let me let me tell you what you
did say then he said that the driver
only trained things is is not really an
issue said 50 of the trains are operated
driver only anyway it's basically saying
that's a strongman argument that you
guys are putting why did they insisted
it going in the document then fifty
percent of the trainers don't run on
that way it's only seven seventy percent
run without it uh and most trains are
operating this country with guards on
board so they did insist on doing that I
had a document I was in a meeting with
the companies on a Sunday afternoon uh
out of hours in order to walk work
towards a settlement on the Saturday on
the Friday the document didn't have
those Clauses in and on the Sunday the
Clauses were reintroduced
as I said yeah no as I said that he he
denies that that happened let's let's
talk about where this goes from here he
can deny all he likes it doesn't mean
it's not true let's talk about where
this goes from here look you're out on
strike four days this week I mean what
do you think you've achieved in terms of
your strike action since you've been out
since the summer
well we brought this this issue to the
to the four what we've done is stop the
companies impose you the 50 cut in
maintenance schedule tasks taking risk
with Railway safety
we've stopped them imposing Mass
redundancies on our members and we've
brought the issue of the the lack of a
square deal for working people in
Britain to the front page of uh and the
front of all the news bulletins in the
country and we've woken up working
people to the fact that they're being
ripped off that they're underpaid and
their conditions are are under threat
right across our economy and right
across our society so that we've had a
game changer really across this year or
across 2022 in terms of what
working-class people are prepared to put
aren't we with and we've put the
government and corporate Britain Under
Pressure to give British workers a
square deal and give them value for
money for their labor
I mean do you get concerned though that
you might with all this disruption it's
the start of the new year you're going
to start alienating some of the public
with these tactics
well we don't want to alienate anyone we
want to run the railway service properly
we want a safe affordable Railway that's
running the interest of the people
rather than the profiteers the private
sector Railway companies that made
profit right through the covid pandemic
and every day during these strikes
they've made profits because the
government is subsidizing the strike so
we don't think we're losing public
support we're getting massive support
from people online in person on our
picket lines and even when our members
are at work on non-strike days the
traveling public is telling us they
support us they want a decent Railway
that's running their interests and they
don't want this inaction from the
government and profiteering from the
private sector Railway so as soon as we
can get a settlement and get the public
back on the railway and back to work and
using Leisure facilities to go about
their business the better for us and the
better for them yeah uh I mean on public
support ipsos did some polling that says
that there was less support for the
strikes and December than there was in
October so it does seem to be going down
a little bit but we'll just leave that
there for now I mean look there's a
payoff run on the table isn't there
there's a there's an offer for
um your conditions as well what more do
you want to see in terms of the offer
because as the transportation is saying
there that's there for you guys what
more do you want to see from them
well we the network rail offer there are
two different offers on the table the
network rail offer was rejected by our
members because of the conditions that
are on it it's not a terribly high value
uh payoffer so there's got to be an
improvement on the pay we're looking for
and we're looking for an agreement on
our conditions and we're looking for an
agreement on job security all of that is
achievable in the next few days the
companies know what they need to do and
they know what we could accept because
they're experienced people it's the
government that is stopping this happen
now I hope Mark Harper and you Merriman
can move this forward in the next few
days so that we can end this dispute
that we can put a set of proposals to
our members in referendums that they can
support but at the minute that's simply
not there our proposals and our needs
are quite modest from this this dispute
and if we can get towards a settlement
the happier we will be and our members
can get back to work you said an
agreement on job security I mean you've
got an agreement until 2025 on no
compulsory redundancies you want it to
go further than that
that's not particularly the issue the
length of the deal with network rail
it's what we've got to do we have to
accept a 50 cut in maintenance schedules
tasks on the railway the company wants
to introduce risk-based maintenance
rather than plan preventative
maintenance we think that's unsafe for
the public we think it's unsafe for our
people and it's not the way to run our
Railway on a more riskier basis than it
is there's also disruption to their
working lives and there are thousands of
job cuts on the table so we need a
settlement that addresses all of the
issues and not just one element
so if we can get that we can move this
forward as quickly as we can
and look there are talks come in as
we've heard and you said you wanted to
have talks with Mr Harper today if you
don't get what you want in these next
round of talks so you're going to step
up this action
well we've got a mandate that runs
through to May uh and we could probably
uh we would ballot again if we haven't
got a settlement we don't want to have
to do that we want to get our members
back to work so the quicker we can get
that the better but we have a mandate
for industrial election that runs on uh
all through the winter and all through
the spring and our members have voted
for industrial action twice and our
Network rail members have voted to turn
down the proposals that are on the table
so we need an improvement in the offer
so that we can get this thing sorted out
and if you don't get it what more days a
week out you're out four days this week
is it going to be seven days I mean that
next week where'd you take this to we've
got no action we've got no action uh on
the stocks at the moment we'll review
that next week when our members are back
at work uh and we'll consult our
Representatives around the country and
we'll decide what the next steps are
after that in the meantime I hope we can
get these discussions on if the
government is saying to me they want to
speak to us as quickly as possible we'll
deal with that before we set down any
more industrial action but we need to
get tangible improvements on what's been
proposed yeah you've made that point Mr
Lynch but I mean passengers who have
been disrupted on their commute back
into work this week people trying to get
around the country to see family and
stuff they'd like to try and know what
might be coming in the next couple of
weeks from Railway workers who are on
strike you're not going to tell us where
you might take this action you're
already out for four days as I said well
we haven't we haven't we haven't got a
schedule of uh further industrial
election at the moment what we do is we
put down a schedule of industrial action
we review what that what that's done
where the talks are and what our members
feel about the action that's taken so
after this action that finishes on
Saturday we'll review that early next
week along with any progress in the
talks that Mr Harper has
indicated he wants to achieve and we'll
see what needs to be done we don't have
a schedule set out six months in advance
we take it in stages and we'll do that
when we review where the dispute is next
week when when this phase is concluded
all right Mick lyncher from the rmt to
appreciate your time this morning thanks
for being with us